- Hey guys it's Justine
and today I'm unboxing
something really exciting.
I just ordered this and
it arrived very quickly
which I'm very excited about
because I really wanted
what was inside this box
and it's crazy because
this isn't a new product,
but I thought it'd be really fun
to just unbox it, show it to you,
see the types of things that I'm getting
during the lockdown.
Who would've thought
that there was a shortage
of this product?
I don't know.
(upbeat music)
- Huh, yes here it is.
You're greeted with a nice
little protective layer
to protect your item.
Here it is.
(laughing) So here it is, we
can take a look (laughing).
This is the front of the box
and you'll see here
that this lets you know
that you can make this in
2 1/2 minute cook time.
Here we have all of our specs.
There's a 100 milligrams of sodium,
25 grams of carbs, and
there's zero sugars.
That's a really great selling point.
Here is a very big
highlight on the spec sheet.
It says that studies have
shown that many Americans
do not consume enough calcium.
And here we have some of the instructions.
Nothing new.
Most products usually come
with instruction booklets,
but this one is just very
nicely marked here on the back
so you don't have to
dig around on the inside
to try to find any loose paper work.
I just appreciate how thorough they are
with everything that they
have on the back of here
because they let you know
the best tips for results.
So when you're preparing this with milk,
just make sure that you watch carefully,
stir to prevent the
milk from boiling over.
They also have a couple
different models of this.
This is the original.
I am a huge fan of just simple, basic,
but if you are interested in other models,
maybe some upgrades, they
have an instant brown sugar,
they also have an instant variety pack,
they have whole grain, and cinnamon.
One of the things you
should always check for
are expiration dates,
so up here they nicely
have that labeled, right
here, March 3rd, of 2022.
Impressive shelf life.
I mean you won't have to
worry about your product
going out of date for quite awhile.
So this is the on button.
You just have to press here,
which I think is kind of misleading
because I'm pressing
and it's not very easy.
It's perforated, but not very well.
It's possible that they did
that for security reasons.
I mean it makes sense.
That was really difficult.
I mean I had to actually cut this open
to get it to turn on.
Do the smell test.
Kind of smells like a new Mac.
Well now that we pretty
much have this all set up,
all opened, all unboxed, I
think that the next logical step
is to go test it out and see how it works.
Okay, the time has come to
really give this a test.
We're gonna follow the instructions.
Oops.
Oh gosh, I've already not
followed these directions.
Oh shoot, that was a little too much.
(upbeat music)
(water pouring)
You don't really have to be
that precise about measurements.
I think it's gonna come out just fine.
So I'm gonna be putting this in here
to really make sure we can
maximize all of the testing
that we can possibly do.
High for one minute
and then we stir again.
And then we continue to cook
for an additional one to two minutes.
I can't wait for breakfast tomorrow.
(sanitizer spraying)
Oh, so one of the things that
you need to watch out for,
is you gotta make sure
it doesn't boil over.
So this is kind of just
a midway little stir
with a wire whisk.
It didn't say how how much to stir,
so I'm using my own good judgment.
(microwave beeping)
My mom always told me not to stand
too close to the microwave
because it would affect me,
my brain, but I gotta keep an eye on it
because it's gonna overflow.
Ah!
This looks like a perfect
consistency to me,
do you think?
(whisk tapping)
You can always add some
upgrades if you choose.
For my upgrade today, we're gonna be going
with a Mountain Forest raw
honey and some cinnamon
that is labeled twice as cinnamon.
This is probably an off brand, generic
which is totally cool as
long as it's compatible
with your current device,
you should be fine.
A little bit of this honey.
Just a little.
And I think our upgrade's complete.
Let's try it.
It's really hot, oh my gosh.
This is great.
I definitely recommend this
version to everyone, for sure.
Well thank you guys so much for watching.
I know this probably
isn't the first unboxing
that has been done of this product.
I'm sure every other tech reviewer
has also unboxed this,
but I just really wanted to kind of give
my take on it and show you
what I got today in the mail.
And I just really hope
that everyone is being safe
and getting enough calcium.
So some of you guys are
confused as to what's happening,
on Twitter I was having this conversation
because I was looking for Cream of Wheat
and I couldn't find it anywhere online.
I didn't want to go to the store
and the last time that
I had gone to the store,
they didn't have any, so I
just didn't know what to do.
So on Twitter somebody
said, "Hey, check Walmart."
Guess what?
Walmart had basically one box
and they said that it
would get here by Monday.
It actually arrived overnight.
I had Cream of Wheat freakin' FedExed
to my house from Walmart.
That is the time that
we're living in right now.
Everything is so weird.
I can't wait for breakfast tomorrow.